the reason why we remember specific
moments on movies is because they have
been stored in our memory under the
influence of emotions when we win or
fail cry or celebrate we learn fast deep
and plenty but when we are afraid our
brain limits our ability to think for a
good reason
fear is an emotion induced when we face
a threat to our physical or
psychological well-being it causes a
change in brain and organ functions and
ultimately in our behavior first we get
stressed or aggressive then we are left
with three final ways out freeze
fight-or-flight
the reason for this is evolution over
the last million years we learned that
when we meet a dangerous animal we'd
better freeze fight or run and hide to
save our life this is now programmed in
our genes but something else happens
when it gets dangerous a specific region
of our brain the amygdala takes over
each job is to protect us and save our
life to act fast it refrains us from
thinking and leaves us with only those
three options
this makes creative and critical thought
processes impossible high-pressure trick
is a similar response in one experiment
German neuroscientist professor dr.
hooter measured the brain function of
young men playing a car racing game the
race was on and the men eager to win
when the researchers later looked at the
scans of the brain they saw shockingly
little activity in fact the young men
hardly used their brains at all and they
certainly didn't remember much
later the research is repeated the
experiment this time they did not play
the game themselves but just watched
from inside the car sitting next to the
driver instead of focusing to win they
focused on a lot of other things driving
behavior the racetrack other cars this
time the brain showed you lots of
activity learning happened and the
memories were created the scientists
concluded that when we panic at a math
exam or when a Salesman fears he might
miss his monthly target it can create a
tunnel vision then our vision field
becomes smaller our learning too limited
and we cannot find the road to success
next time when you were stressed to
perform or when you panic during an exam
try this quick fix first
slowly breathe in through your nose to
do it slow enough count from 1 to 5 then
breathe out through your mouth again
count into five repeat that for 1 to 5
minutes and your body will relax and
your brain can switch from protection
mode back to a learning mode what is
your personal experience do you think we
should apply pressure and push for a
goal in order to maximize our learning
or do you think we should free our minds
from pressure and goals please share
your thoughts in the comments below
thanks for watching even if we try to
keep it short each video is quite some
work first we research and write a
script then we brainstorm ideas and
after that we draw the storybook then is
recorded narrated and finally edited if
you want to support us to make more
videos on learning and education visit
patreon.com slash sprouts
[Music]
[Music]